- Hey guys.
Thank you for having me.
This is a beautiful room.
I'm very excited to be here.
And very honestly, I do want
to get into Q&A pretty quickly,
and I don't want to
bore you with my life story
or things of that nature.
But here's where I will go.
In doing some of my
homework before I got here
and some of the
talking that we did beforehand,
what I really feel
excitement about is even more so
than in the U.S. market,
where I've been able to
what I call day trade attention.
Which is, very simply, no
matter what you do in this room,
you've got to
communicate your value, right?
No matter what
you do in this room,
whether you're in B to B,
whether you're in B to C,
whatever you sell,
whatever you do,
if you're running for office,
if you're trying
to raise money for a non-profit,
if you're trying to sell
sneakers, if you're a lawyer,
if you're trying to raise your
profile to get a promotion,
or get a different job.
Regardless of what
you do, what your real job
at the macro is to find
where people's attention is
and then try to figure out how
to communicate your value prop.
When I see a market
like this that has decided,
and this is holistically,
this is not every
individual person,
but has decided things like
television or outdoor media,
or even more
specifically, direct mail,
become the
preference points in a world
where Facebook has
such underpriced
attention potential,
it just gets me very excited.
The reason we opened a
VaynerMedia London office is
when we carefully looked
at the cost of Facebook ads
in western Europe,
they were stunning to us
on how much
better of a deal it was
than the U.S. penetration.
What's interesting
about that, and some of you
that follow me know this,
and usually when I talk,
I talk in U.S. marketing terms,
we believe that
Facebook is disproportionately
the best deal in the marketplace
today in that market.
So, as you can imagine, it
created enormous excitement
for me about the
potential in markets
like Belgium, U.K., and
other places of that nature.
For me, very simply, this
speech is
one minute of content,
which is, everything
I've done for 20 years
has been the same exact move.
What does everybody
spend their time and money
and energy on?
Is that worth it?
And then what can
I do that is emerging,
that is underpriced, because
people don't have reports
to justify it at
Corporate America?
Or, on the entrepreneurial
level, they're scared
to do it because
they're fake entrepreneurs.
For me, that has been the
tried-and-true real history
of my career.
It started all the way
back when I got involved
in my dad's liquor store.
It is literally only
20 years ago,
now almost 21 years ago,
which is not that long of
a time if you really think
about it, that when we
launched WineLibrary.com,
everybody told me and
my dad that it was a fad.
Forget about is SnapChat a fad.
Forget about if
Instagram is a fad.
The entire internet was
a fad if you were really
a business person
in 1995, 1996, 1997.
It's fascinating to think that.
It's the same way
that many of you in here
probably don't realize if
you're not studying the space,
that we're probably
only 20 or 30 years away
from virtual reality
making the internet obsolete
and all of us just
living in contact lenses
and in a VR world,
and the real world
and the internet
world become arbitraged out
because what will
happen is our attention
will now be in a
new virtual reality.
For me, this is
how my brain works.
To me, I'm not a digitalist
over a traditionalist.
For example, in
the American market,
one of the things I'm really
pushing our clients towards
is actually radio.
There's a
platform called IHeartRadio
that I believe that the ads on
that platform are underpriced
for the attention because people
listen to that programming.
When the disc jockey
jumps in and reads a live ad,
I actually think
that's a good deal.
That confuses a
lot of my friends
that think I'm a digitalist.
In America, if you
were to launch a product,
and you had
$20 million to launch it,
the first thing I would
do is buy a Super Bowl ad.
Because in America,
every single person
watches the
Super Bowl commercials.
And so, this is how I trade.
This is how I think.
And the truth is,
much like what's happening
with your agency,
I've always thought
it was a huge
advantage to not be in America,
not be in Silicon Valley.
In a world where so much
of what we do is just human,
not American or
European, or Asian.
It's just human psychology,
not everything maps.
Obviously Americans
are more comfortable
being outspoken and in front.
Some countries
are more reserved.
Some countries have
political instability
that makes them scared to share.
There's different
variables across the world.
But when I look at this market,
it's interesting
to me and exciting.
Because the truth is,
you actually get to watch
the future play out
in a different market
and then all you have to do is
interpret it to your market.
And then all you
have to do is be patient.
See, the real reality here is,
the far majority of
upside sits in this room
with the individuals
here that map similar
to my overall thesis,
which is they're patient,
and they're waiting
for it to come to them.
But they're good enough in
staying alive to get there.
The backbone of my success
that I don't talk a lot about
is the fact that
I'm so good at sales
that I can scrounge by.
And that's what
the VaynerMedia was.
In 2009, '10, '11, when nobody
wanted to buy social media,
I was good enough to
just get by, stay alive,
stay alive, stay alive.
But, I was the loudest and
proudest about
believing in this.
I had to be right.
Because again, in 2009,
'10, '11, most people thought
these sites would go away.
This was coming on
the back of Myspace--
(phone ringing) Make
sure you pick that up.
(audience laughter)
This was on the back of
Myspace in the U.S. market
and people were still debating
if every site would have
a one or two year thing.
Everybody was very
emotional about investing
in new platforms.
I had to stay alive.
I was able to stay alive, and
then the market came to me.
Patience is such a big deal.
The thing that concerns me,
and that I'm curious about
in this room, is of the
300-plus people in here,
how many people
actually sell something
they fully believe
in in their heart,
versus they sell it
because it's what they're doing,
or it's what
they've committed to,
and it's where
their money is tied into?
To me, this is a very
important part of being
in the agency,
brand, startup world.
If you do not fundamentally
believe in what you're selling,
and I mean really, not
how you posture to each other,
but how do you talk to yourself
in your own brain at night.
If you do not,
you're vulnerable.
You're very vulnerable
for many different reasons.
But my belief is now looking
at the global
advertising market.
It's amazing to me.
When I go to Cannes every year,
I'll sit on a panel like this.
Usually with somebody from
WPP and somebody from Omnicom,
and a big brand, and usually
it's a gang up session,
three against me.
Which is usually a blowout
because I can
slaughter the three of them.
It's not enough.
They bash me.
Tried-and-true reporting,
bullshit reporting,
Nielsens, Millward Brown
horseshit, fake math.
And then we'll end,
then we'll leave.
And then,
at 3:00 in the morning,
after 11 glasses of rosé,
they'll see me at
the Carlton Hotel.
They'll come up to
me and they'll say,
"Psst. You're right."
I find this to be the
single most fascinating thing
about the advertising
and marketing landscape.
In a world where
Facebook is disproportionately
the best direct-to-consumer
advertising,
the fact that Wine Library,
my family business,
has moved all of its direct
mail business into Facebook.
The math isn't even close.
There's people in here
doing direct mail marketing
who have made a
decision that that works
without spending
the same amount of money
on Facebook to
see if that works.
We are living in a
headline-reading society.
Everybody has opinions.
Everybody has
opinions about everything,
but they're not
actual practitioners.
You can't have an
opinion on Snapchat
or Snapchat ads if
you've never used it.
You can't have a
smart opinion to me
if you've run
$1,000 in Facebook ads
and have made
your entire decision
on the plethora of opportunites
on the platform on $1,000.
Clients tell me
all the time,
"Gary, we know
television commercials work,
"we don't if know
if Facebook works."
I go, "No shit,
you spent $8 million on
"a television
commercial campaign
"in production and distribution,
"and you spent
$100,000 testing Facebook."
Of course it's
not going to work.
And so we live
in this environment
where people go and play safe.
You make decisions, so many
of you in here make decisions
on what's best for your
career in the short-term,
not what actually sells shit.
And to me, that's where
all the opportunity sits.
That's where the action is,
that's the white space.
That's why in America,
in the fashion industry,
every brand is in trouble
because there are thousands
of little brands doing Facebook
and Instagram influencers,
and they're chopping
away at the big brands.
Ralph Lauren's
biggest problem isn't Prada,
it's 41 women and men
startups that are doing
from zero to three
million in revenue in one year
because they're marketing
in underpriced channels
while Ralph Lauren and
Prada are buying full page ads
in fuckin' Vogue
that nobody's seeing.
This is happening,
this is happening every day.
And here's the
funniest part, I know
that everybody in this
room knows it's happening.
I just don't know if it actually
is in your best interest
for it be happening
in the short-term.
That to me is the bet,
that to me is the strategy.
That is the only thing I care
about pushing in this room.
It's why I want to go
to Q&A sooner, I'd rather go
into details 'cause
the thesis is very simple.
I can say this
again five more times
and get to the Q&A part,
but it will not change,
it will be the same thing.
I will give you
four different analogies
for the same fucking thing.
Attention has a price,
everything still works,
the problem is most
things are overpriced.
For example, in
America and the globe,
programmatic buying for digital
has completely taken over.
Why? It's profitable
for media agencies.
But it's not good for
brands and businesses.
Who the hell here
goes to a desktop computer
and goes to blah
blah blah dot com
and goes to the
right side of the website
below the fold and
clicks a banner ad?
Nobody.
So in a world where
I put enormous pressure
on my clients to move
money away from television
because nobody,
nobody in the U.S. market
and nobody in the global
market, if you look at the math,
is really consuming a
television commercial.
Every single time
you're in a position
where a television
commercial is about
to give you
something, you grab this
and you check your
work, you talk about
what you just watched
'cause you're watching...
I love when my
competitors on stage say,
"Gary, television
ratings are through the roof."
I'm like, "Yes,
television shows."
Everybody likes to sneak
in commercials with shows.
You're watching the show,
you're watching the match.
You're not watching the
piece of shit commercial.
In a world where I'm
trying to move all my clients
away from that, when
they come to me and say,
"Hey Gary, great
news, we're going digital."
I get scared because I'm even
more scared of banner ads
and pop-up ads than I am
of television commercials.
So when people go
digital I get scared
'cause I think they're
going digital 2002 to 2005.
In 2002, when I was
buying the word wine,
and buying the word champagne,
and buying the word bordeaux
for five cents a
click, that was good.
And now, some of those words
are properly priced at $4.12,
for Wine Library,
champagne is good.
At $11, the word wine,
it is not good.
Every single day, if
I came here, seven months ago
I would have told
you that I was concerned
about Instagram globally,
especially in the U.S. market.
Because Snapchat
was getting older,
Facebook's younger
than people think,
and I was questioning
where would Instagram play.
Instagram, as a lot of you know,
copied every single feature
that Snapchat had, grew,
exploded, and now Instagram,
seven months later is
my number one platform
that I'm paying
attention to and marketing on.
This is day trading attention.
This is not
making a commitment to,
in 2017, it's all about Snapchat
and then just sticking to
it, no matter what happens.
No, no, no, this
is, on February 19th,
this is the best trade.
On March 16th,
My friends, here's the
part that really scares me,
which is, as the world continues
to change very quickly,
the truth and the
rules always stay the same.
For example, for all
the math that we now have,
the creative is the
variable of success.
The video, the
picture, the words,
the sounds, the creative
is the variable of success.
When people hear me talk.
It's interesting
'cause I talk about creative
in a lot of interesting ways.
Number one, I think
creative is 100% subjective.
I understand why if
you're the creative director
of an organization
you don't want that
necessarily to be
true, you've worked hard
for 20 years to
build a reputation
so that you can walk in and say,
that's not funny enough,
that's not green enough,
that wasn't
snarky enough, I get it.
The problem is the
market doesn't give a fuck
about you Han.
(audience laughter)
So creative is
subjective until it comes out
to the market and
then the market decides
if it was funny,
snarky or green enough.
But creative is the variable.
At Vayner we are very
much obsessed with attention
and the platform
and the context.
How do you
story tell on Facebook
different than
Pinterest different
than a pre-roll on
Google different than
an original piece of
content different than
a native ad on
Buzzfeed different, different,
different, different.
It's context along with content.
However, there
is no misconception
that the creative itself
is the variable of success.
And so the thing
that excites me though
is that we live in a world.
So for Vayner
right now we're obsessed
with one thing, obsessed.
You give me a brief,
you want to do something.
You want to sell this,
right, you want to sell this.
The first two
things I think about
is number one,
how do I make one to,
depending on your budget,
one to seven
different videos that are
a minute and 19 seconds long
that are gonna hit the emotional
center of the individual?
But not one, not
one 30 second spot
because I promise you
if you're 44 years old
and make $400,000 a
year and you're a male
this brand means
something different to you
than if you're 18
years old and a female
and making $27,000 a year.
And how in the world
would I talk to both of you
the same way to
make you buy this?
That's insanity.
It wasn't insanity when we lived
in a television first world,
it was your only option,
life's about options.
I'm not mad at
people that made TV spots
and billboards and
direct mail in 1984,
that was the game, I'm
mad at everybody in this room
that are acting like
it's 1984 when it's 2017.
That's the problem.
So I have to make seven videos.
And they don't have to be
15 and 30s and 60 seconds,
we did that because
that's how television sold them.
The fuck are you
making 30 second videos
for Facebook for?
It makes no sense.
And I don't mean,
well everybody says
we've got to make them short
because they read a headline
that attention spans
are short on Facebook.
Meanwhile as a practitioner
DRock and I are putting
out 25 minute
videos on Facebook everyday
and I'm watching everybody
watch the whole fuckin' thing.
Content is content.
If it's good, it works.
If it's bad, it's bad.
You could make a six second Vine
that people won't watch three
seconds 'cause is sucks shit.
And you can make
a four hour movie
and if it's the
best four hour movie ever
everybody will sit nice and
calm in a theater like this
and watch every second.
And so these are the
things that I think about.
The other thing, and
this is a huge opportunity
in this market 'cause this is
one thing I did do last night
'cause I had to stay up 'til
four o'clock in the morning
to do something on
the west coast in the U.S.
And this is something I
dug into a little bit here.
I implore you, you
too, I implore you guys
to start looking at influencer
marketing very serious.
Influencer marketing
is grossly underpriced
more so than anything I've seen
except for
Facebook three years ago
and Google 10 years ago.
Individuals, humans
that have followings.
Especially in the way, you
know I asked you a question
about Instagram,
I looked at it last night,
it's emerging much
quicker and quieter here
than I think people realize.
Instagram influencers
that can bring value
to your brand and
story at extremely low costs
including just
giving them the product,
they're just
happy to get it for free
and they'll give you media
in return that's incredible.
The two places if
you're trying to sell something
that are grossly
under priced in this market
are Facebook ads in video
form and influencer marketing.
Is it at the scale of
the U.S., absolutely not,
is that really
interesting to me?
Of course, 'cause the
price is much lower here too.
And when you look at
the gross over investment
on direct mail
in this environment,
that arbitrage is
extremely attractive.
What I don't
understand is why in a world
where people are
spending hundreds of thousands
of Euros in a
direct mail campaign
why that can't be 75,000
and they take 25,000
to at least become educated
if what I'm talking about
is real or bullshit.
Like to me, I don't
care if I'm right or wrong,
I'm just blown away that
you're willing to not find out.
We just sit with our
thoughts and theories
of what's tried-and-true.
Let me tell you something,
what got you here today
is not gonna get
you to the next place.
And we sit in theory
and we sit in romance
and we sit in how,
you know how many people
in this room make
business decisions
on how they wish
the world was working?
They're sad
that when they go out
to a restaurant or cafe
they see people sitting there
and both looking at the phone,
they're upset about that.
They've made a
romantic decision on how
the world should be.
I see that and I'm
happy because I realize
those people
want to be doing that.
I'm thrilled that
this woman in the third row
is looking at her
phone, I'm happy for you.
Because that's what she
wants to be doing right now.
I'm not upset
'cause I'm talking,
I don't give a
fuck about my feelings,
that's what she wants to do.
That right there
is the punchline.
The market is always
right, not your fuckin' ego.
And I've got nothin' but ego.
But when it comes to the market
I only have humility.
The market is always right.
And we sit in
ivory towers thinking
we're super fuckin'
smart and we disrespect
the market every day
and that's why we lose.
In last years fiscal year
96% of the Fortune 500
companies in the
world lost market share.
They lost
market share because
they're marketing
like it's 2005,
like it's 1997,
they're marketing
like it's 1984,
that's why they
lost market share.
And I know this because
there's only one other time
that we have seen
this big of businesses
lose this much
global market share,
it was the
late '40s and early '50s
when the world transitioned
from radio to television.
My friends, we are transitioning
from television to this.
It's already happened.
I've been here for a long time.
I implore you to join me.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
Can we put the
lights on for Q&A?
- Yeah that'd be great.
Yeah, now that's good.
I should have done that earlier.
I was just focusing
on these 18 people.
Sorry back there.
Yeah, so, I'd
love to do Q&A.
I mean that's the
philosophy, and honestly,
I know a lot of
people here may follow,
I went very marketing
heavy because I try
to kind of gauge the room, but
if people want to
talk about startup world,
you know something that a
lot of you who don't know me
may not know.
Back in 2007-8, I invested
in Facebook and Twitter
and Tumblr, and have
had a very good career,
Uber, things of that
nature, and that world.
If you want to talk
about building a business,
I've run two
businesses in my life.
Both of them I grew from,
one from zero to a
$100 million in seven years,
one from three to
$60 million in seven years.
So I think I know what it takes.
One from three to 150 employees,
one from zero to 800 employees.
So if you want to
talk about management
or building organizations,
HR, we can go there.
(audience laughter)
You like that one?
Good, awesome.
So, wherever you want to go.
Who's got questions?
Great, let's get you a mic.
Thanks for
breaking the ice, my friend.
What's your name?
Make sure you give me your name.
- [Hans] My name is Hans.
- Hans (laughs)
(audience laughter)
- [Hans] I really
loved your talk
with Adriana Huffington.
- Yes.
- [Hans] About value of sleep.
- [Hans] Because that's
an item that's not a lot
getting noticed in your posts.
- For me.
- [Hans] Yeah.
- Correct, I agree.
That's why I had her on,
because I wanted to clear it up,
once and for all.
- [Hans] Exactly.
- You want me to expand on it?
- [Hans] I'm a big fan of
silence for me,
as a way to
recharge my batteries.
And center and focus on
what I want to do, and why.
- Yes.
- [Hans] Now, I
would like to hear,
what's your take on
the value of silence,
and is there
- Silence?
- [Hans] Silence,
is there a place for it
in your 24/7/365 life?
- No.
(audience laughter)
But that's good.
This is important for everybody.
It's amazing
that you're self-aware
and you know your hard wiring,
that silence is
important to you.
The thing that I fear
as I grow in popularity,
is that people
try to emulate me.
And the reason I
continue to put out,
now, I want to talk
about what I think is
the way I do it so
people can use me as a blueprint
for themselves.
But the reason every
two weeks, three weeks,
four weeks, I'll say something
that throws them off,
is I want to remind them
that I'm just one human being
and this is what works for me.
I'm the reverse.
Something that, you know,
I'm sure DRock's
laughing right now.
There's times when
we walk into the office
and it's quiet because
everybody's on headphones
and trying to be respectful,
and it freaks me out.
I need volume.
Like I need the
light to see your faces.
I need the stimulation.
I suffocate in silence.
Of course when I'm
exhausted, these guys
picked me up last night, we
flew from New York to Ireland.
One-hour nap, all day Ireland,
flight, they picked me up.
I had to get mentally ready.
I wanted to catch up
with him but I was kinda like,
I needed a little bit of
silence, sometimes I need it.
But 99% of the time,
when I'm awake,
I need action.
You know?
And so,
but you have to understand,
and I think we're
going to connect on this.
I'm only
comfortable and at peace
in the chaos.
When I get silence,
I get sad, I get anxious.
It's not interesting to me,
so I think the key here is
to just know yourself,
and not try to map to,
oh this person.
One of the biggest reasons
I go after Steve Jobs's legacy
is because I want to build the
biggest company in the world,
and I want to do it by
being nice to my people.
But all the kids
in Silicon Valley
after Steve Jobs got so big,
everybody heard how tough
he was on people,
so they were faking it.
I had good people, good
friends, who I knew very well,
start being assholes at work
'cause they thought
that's how you had to do it
to be successful.
Fuck that.
I think you get much more
out of honey than vinegar.
Much more from people.
So,
you know, I'm
comfortable doing it my way.
I have no interest in
imposing my way on you.
I think it's important
for you to see how I do it.
The reason we
started DailyVee, the vlog,
is, when I was talking about
hustling and working hard,
people interpreted
that differently.
Now that they see it,
they're like, fuck.
You know, am I really,
is that really me?
Do I want it that bad?
Like to achieve greatness,
wow, it takes real work.
You know everybody,
everybody's fascinated by luck,
or the big idea.
It doesn't exist.
You don't know a single
person that's made it big
unless they
worked their face off.
You might know somebody
who inherited a lot of money
from mommy and daddy.
They may be rich,
but they didn't build it.
Anybody you've ever
met that built something
worked their fucking face off.
You got it.
(audience applause)
Questions.
Let's go with this lovely lady.
We'll get you back there next.
Hi.
- Hi Gary.
I'm Noriko.
I'm Japanese,
living here in Belgium,
I've been translating your
videos--
- I'm very aware,
it's good to see you.
Thank you for your help.
- It's really my
pleasure thanks to your team.
- Hold on one second,
is there any way she can hold it
so she can get it closer?
Is that alright with you?
Thank you. Thank you.
- So, thank you--
- Little closer.
- Okay? Alright.
Thanks to your team,
getting here, so
you just talked about
honey and vinegar.
But I really can see,
you're not just talking,
but you have wonderful people
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I really want to say
to everyone.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- So my question is
about negative comments.
- [Gary] Negative comments.
- Any platforms you get,
- [Gary] Yes.
- And you talk about
this also on the videos
and I totally understand
because I have thick skin,
and I really, like in your
terms, I don't give a fuck.
I really don't care.
But, I help small
business people, and when it
comes to my clients,
that's a different story
because they get
stuck, they got hurt,
so they can't put
enough content because
they don't want to get it--
- Most people are
not putting out work
because they're scared
of other people's feedback.
And the second they get
negative feedback they collapse,
and they go in a cacoon.
- So is there a
way somehow that I can
convince them to move on--
- Yes, and no, let me explain.
This is a self-esteem game.
So, there's no
drug for self-esteem.
People in here who were
unfortunate and had parents,
or were hard-wired in a way
that lacked self-esteem,
you're not going to be
able to fix that overnight.
You can't just be a cheerleader,
and for two minutes
they'll be like, "yeah"
and then you walk away
and they're like, "no".
So,
there's a couple things:
first and foremost,
negative comments.
I really don't
give a fuck either,
however, I take every
one of them seriously.
I think the
biggest thing that is
missing in the world today,
politically, globally, business
is empathy.
We lack empathy,
in today's society, at a
level that is very intriguing.
I'm trying to go
backwards and figure out
why over the last
30 years, 40 years
have we lost so much empathy.
Or, do we just not have it?
Is that just a skill that humans
have always underperformed in?
Which is, by the way, something
that I'm starting to realize
looks like it's
gonna be the case.
But we lack
empathy, so the biggest,
when I get
negative comments,
the reason I
like looking at them is
I respect, back to making
that joke of that lovely lady,
they're the market.
They think I'm full of shit!
They think I'm too egotistical,
they think I'm wrong.
I want to
understand why, and I want to
respect that
they're coming with it.
Most negative comments,
especially 'cause I have
a lot of young dude fans,
come at very harsh terminology,
I don't respect the
vulgar, or the language.
But I do respect the energy.
I've done, is
I've done it upfront.
So before you
even start with them,
I'm very aggressive of
like, this is going to happen.
And really getting there.
And spending a lot of
time in the beginning,
so that instead when it happens,
and they look at
you and go, "woah!",
you've already had that talk.
And I mean,
really have the talk.
It's probably with
small businesses what I spend
70% of my energy on,
in getting them
mentally prepared
for somebody saying,
"Your ice cream sucks."
But they're
used to it in America
in some ways because of Yelp,
and they've been
dealing with that.
But yeah I mean,
what makes me so
sad, at the macro,
is those couple
of negative comments
compared to all the
upside of producing content
and being on the offense,
and being aggressive.
The weight is,
right?
Yet, unfortunately, so
many people are crippled
by even one negative comment.
Because of their
own internal wiring.
It's a challenge.
What I would say is
you need to be patient,
and you need to
be understanding.
Because, you can't just
instill self-esteem overnight.
You got it. You're welcome.
Questions.
- [Bart] Hello.
- Hey.
- I'm Bart, I practiced
my question so many times
that I lost my voice.
(audience laughter)
- That's amazing.
- [Bart] First of all, I would
like to thank you because
I started my career
as an entrepreneur by
trying to build
the next Facebook.
But thanks to your
speeches on self-awareness,
I came to realize that I
lose sleep over borrowing
a hundred euros from my
brother so I probably will
never build the next Facebook.
Having that in mind.
So, a year ago,
I started to build a data
migration company, organically.
So, I landed a
big customer, and now
I get paid every day,
and I'm developing my stuff.
And we went live in
production in Chile,
in December.
This year for the
same company we will do
USA, Mexico and Canada.
So it's growing really great.
But my question to you was,
you talk a lot about patience,
but you also talk
sometimes about speed.
And patience
for me that would be
continue with the same--
- Can I answer you
real fast and you'll
understand it forever?
- [Bart] Okay.
- Macro, patience. Micro, speed.
- [Bart] Yeah. Okay.
- And let me expand on it,
'cause that didn't work.
Fuck.
No no, hold on, hold
on, hold on, back back back.
Macro-patience.
You're a young man.
Building something
meaningful, a relationship,
a business, it
takes 10, 20, 30 years.
On your day-to-day work,
you have to be fast.
With the clients, they email
you, you email them back.
Like, your day-to-day.
But your vision?
What you want
to achieve in life?
You're not going to
build it in one year.
And so many
people have it reversed.
In the day-to-day, they're slow,
and in the macro, they
want their business to be huge
the next day.
So you need to reverse it.
- [Bart] So if you have to
make the decision between,
in my case,
building a better framework
or focusing on that, or
trying to find more customers,
what would you advise?
Knowing that I don't need
the money of new customers
right now.
- Both.
- [Bart] Okay.
(audience laughter)
- And so here's another,
here's an answer of both:
Number one, how
hard are you working?
I don't know.
If you're
working 12 hours a day,
I feel like you could
work 17 if you want! Right?
Number two, if
you're working every hour,
and you can't work more,
with the money that's coming in,
too many young people
and too many young businesses
when they start
having money come in,
take it for themselves.
They want to buy a good watch.
They want to buy a good car.
They want to buy fancier shoes.
What I would do is,
when my first money,
so here's my story.
This is not advice
I'm giving just for fun.
This is my life.
I walked in my dad's store,
it did $3 million a year,
10 percent gross profit,
$300,000 dollars in profit
before expenses,
we had no money,
I was making $40,000 a year,
37,4, actually.
And I built that
business from 3 to 45 million,
in the first kind
of four or five years,
and five years later,
five years later this is doing
$45 million dollars in sales,
and I'm making $40,000 dollars.
This is the advice I gave.
And by the way, I was
in my twenties, and a guy.
The exact time, if you're
making that kind of money,
that you want to use it
to do guy things.
Right?
I put it back into the business,
I hired four more managers,
six more managers,
seven more managers,
I did more advertising.
I built a business.
So if this money's coming from
Chile and U.S. and Mexico,
hire people.
Then you can do both.
- [Bart] Okay. Thanks.
- You're welcome.
Questions.
Great, now they're coming.
Okay, here we go up there.
- [David] Hello,
I'm David, my question
is a bit in line
with the former question,
it's about building a business
and growing and having...
being scared about
growing the business.
- Okay.
- [David] It
would push me to more
be saving money then investing
in technology in the future.
What would be your advice?
- David, I want to
make sure I understand.
You're saying that you
need to deploy capital.
So, here's my
advice in investing.
How old are you?
- [David] I'm 40.
- Four zero?
- [David] Four zero, yeah.
- You look great!
- [David] Tomorrow,
ha, tomorrow.
- My answer in building a,
everyone's like turning back.
How good does he look?
(audience laughter)
By the way, best part,
this is the truth,
I can't fucking see him.
(audience laughter)
- [David] You can
have a photo with me.
- We'll do it later.
David, my answer
always is, always, is
well, here's a question.
Are you
planning on this business
still being your
business five years from today?
- [David] Yes.
- Okay, then I
would invest every penny
you can afford
that doesn't put you
personally in bankruptcy
or out of business.
- [David] Okay.
- Does that answer the question?
- [David] Yes.
- Great.
- [David] Thank you.
- If you were
looking to sell the business
in the next two or three years,
then there's a debate.
But if you put in the money now,
and you're gonna be in business
in five years and
assuming that you're right,
you're gonna have a
much better business,
and that's why
it's the right bet.
VaynerMedia, VaynerMedia, again,
I always like
when I can give you
examples of what I'm doing.
'Cause, it's not
just me, oh I made it,
let me give advice.
The last two years I've
run VaynerMedia as a CEO.
Two years ago the business did
$67 million in revenue,
its an agency.
Last year it did 100 million.
Both years we made
the same amount of money.
The bottom line made
When you make $33 million
more in revenue,
and you make the
same amount of money
that you did the
year before, you're doing
two things, the two
things I believe in.
One, I'm investing in
the business for real.
Number two,
I took a lot of risks.
Many of which will
work, many of which won't,
but it felt like the right year
to take those risks,
'cause I was tasting
that the business was
gonna go from 67 to 100.
So, I knew that I had the
economics to make those bets.
So, you know,
I think one of the things
that makes me comfortable
and one of the reasons
I want to remind
people in this room,
especially in the
advent of the new digital world
where every 20 year old
thinks they're an expert,
I spent 13 years
bulding a business.
365 days a years,
15 hours a day,
before I ever made a blog post,
before I ever wrote a book,
before I ever gave a speech.
I take a lot of
pride in the fact
that I only give advice
that I actually do myself.
It's your job to interpret where
you and I are different,
because everything
I do won't
necessarily work for you,
but the advice is me
eating what I'm serving.
Cool, let's keep it going.
Let's get this guy right here.
You guys, like,
they told you not to
ask questions, got you.
- [Man] What's up Gary?
- Hey man.
- [Man] I hope you
that I vlogged this.
- I see it. You were saying.
- [Man] So, my question is,
thank you from us,
thank you for
everything you're doing, man.
You changed my life
and my question is that...
Do you know Patrick Bet-David?
- Do I know what?
- Patrick Bet-David. He's
also making videos on YouTube.
- [Gary] I'm not
sure, no I'm sorry.
- One of his videos, he said,
"I don't use business cards
anymore, I only use Linkedin.
"When someone is coming to me,
"I just give them the Linkedin."
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Man] Is that good or not?
Because for now, I'm
starting my business next week
and I'm deciding on if I
want to use business cards
or just, if people ask
for my contact details,
just give them the Linkedin.
- I don't use business cards,
and haven't for a long time,
and not because
I think I'm fancy
and easy to find on
the internet or Linkedin.
It's 'cause I take
their phone and I email them.
The amount of
times I do business cards
and nothing happens,
because we throw them out,
we lose them, we don't care.
So, if I want to do
business with somebody,
I actually take
their physical phone
and have them email me
or I email them on the spot
or I text them on the spot.
Again, making 30 second videos
for a Facebook world,
because that's how television
was formatted is stupid.
You have a business card 'cause
you want to do
business with that person.
To give a business
card, you're physically
in front of that person.
I don't know if you
know, but it's 2017.
This is called a cell phone.
It is much smarter to
create no vulnerability
by making that
transaction happening there.
The end.
- [Man] Thank you so much.
(audience applause)
- And let me tell you,
I'm so glad you asked that,
because in a macro I'm
gonna use that analogy.
I hope DRock caught it
'cause I see him moving around.
That was a very
important moment.
My friends, we
lack common sense.
We go through
school and we get educated
and it takes over
the part of our brain
that is left for common sense.
What I just said is funny.
Some of you snicker, its funny.
It makes so much sense.
We forget why we're doing things
and so we get into the
tactics, not the strategy.
You have business
cards to do fucking business.
All of you have probably
missed minimum 50 percent
of your business card exchanges.
We have this now, use it,
and that's the same
thing for everything.
What was the
purpose of the video?
Not to make a commercial.
To sell somebody on the emotion
of the video so they buy it.
So, if you have
to make that story
in 48 seconds,
make it in 48 seconds.
Not 'cause 30 was
the way we did it.
Facebook's direct mail,
you have they're address.
You actually
know how old they are,
what they care about,
how many kids they have,
when they got married.
You know way more
than the mailbox knows.
What are you doing with your
direct mail when you get home?
Let me save you time.
- It's real.
And by the way, again, history.
History will always
tell you the future.
Go get educated on what happened
in marketing and business
in the late '40s
to the early '50s
in the U.S. and Western Europe.
You will see it.
There was a major transition
because people held on
to the romance of radio
and disrespected the
emergence of television.
Now we're doing
that with the television
instead of the cell
phone and the networks
that dominate the cell phone.
Television, Facebook
is the number one channel
on this television.
You need to become
the number one show
on that channel.
There are a lot more shows
and that comes down to content.
Cool.
Questions?
- [Henrick] Hello
- Oh how are you?
- [Henrick] My name is Henrick.
- Henrick, thank you.
- [Henrick] Thank you,
thank you Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Henrick] I have a question.
Peter and Steven told us
about The Day After Tomorrow
and Tomorrow,
artificial intelligence
and things like that.
- A.I.?
- [Henrick] And A.I.
- Love it.
- [Henrick] And it's something
big companies can buy
the advise ad--
- Do you guys have Alexa Voice?
Do you guys have Alexa here yet?
- [Crowd] No.
- [Henrick] No, not yet.
- You're gonna shit.
(audience laughing)
It's great.
(chuckles)
It's gonna happen
in the U.S. soon to.
Go head.
- [Henrick] So that's a question
you talking about
empathy and things like that.
- Yes.
- [Henrick] Sometimes
when we send an email,
send a message on
Facebook to companies,
I think the
bots are in sleeping.
And so we don't
get information back.
- Yes.
- [Henrick] So they are talking
a lot of it, about it.
What's your point of view
on artificial intelligence--
- It's gonna be, it's gonna be
- [Henrick] And then
the human thing about it?
- I think A.I. is
gonna be enormous.
It makes a lot of sense.
Humans, our brains
are the best computers
in the world, for now.
And so we do too many
things that we don't need
to be doing.
And for the last
forever of human race,
we chip away at the
things we don't need to do.
We got animals to do things
that we didn't have to do.
Like we got
other people to do it.
We got machines.
We are very smart.
A.I. works
because fourteen
hundred people a month
ask me which one
of my four books
they should read.
I don't need to do
that by hand a hundred times
out of luck and
serendipity and timing.
I should answer
that fourteen
hundred times a month
through my decision
and then the A.I. bot
will take care of it.
There are a
million things like that.
Right?
Let me go through it.
When you email
Wine Library, and go
"Where the fucks my wine?"
I have a human
that goes and looks at
where it is on
FedEx, and UPS and DHL.
That doesn't need to happen.
And we've seen that.
Automated emails.
A.I. will be
enormous but all the magic
looks like this.
If the point is to go
from here
to here,
if that's the point.
Where is my wine?
How do I do this?
What book?
What service?
If that's the point,
A.I. at its height
and it's prime
will look like this.
A.I., A.I.,
A.I., A.I., A.I., A.I.,
and for the
really good shit, human.
We just need to
get to 95% of it,
get the human in
the best position
to create the context
because our brain's better
than the A.I. brain, for now
and on the most important stuff.
There's plenty of
things that can be
A.I., A.I.,
A.I., I, I, I, to this.
The companies and the
humans that understand
which ones need to be
A.I., A.I., A.I., I, I, I,
(slapping)
A.I.
Versus A.I., A.I.,
A.I., human, will win.
- [Henrick] So I'm
in the real estate aged.
I'm a traditional
real estate agent.
- Yep.
- [Henrick] So there is a future
for the real estate agent?
- Humans will be fine
until the robots kill us.
(audience laughter)
And what that
means is, I'm not joking.
By the way there
are gonna be two paths
when this is all said and done.
Immortality or
robots took over completely.
We'll probably not see it
but it's very basic
chess, if you actually
understand what's
happening in society.
I prefer not to see it
'cause for somebody
that's not scared of anything,
even that's pretty intense.
I'll be really pissed
if I just miss immortality
by this much,
which is concerning me
'cause I really don't wanna die.
But, yes.
I remember seven
years ago when I would talk
about what was happening,
everybody got scared
that journalists would die.
Right? Because there
was a lot of pressure
against journalism.
And I said, "no, no,
you don't understand,
"it's gonna be better
than ever for journalists
"'cause there's gonna
be more things to do".
There's been plenty
of things that have gone
after real estate
agents, you've heard it.
Technology always
says it's gonna take
everything over.
It's not,
because the human brain
is still winning.
But if things like IBM Watson
and all the future
stuff that's gonna happen
and when A.I. and
V.R. and you know,
we're just starting.
There is a lot more to go.
So yeah, I don't
think, I never bet against
innovation and technology.
That being said, you'll
see your career through.
- [Henrick] We have
the same idea, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Henrick] Good confirmation.
- Good.
-Awesome, who do we got?
Yep.
Awesome.
- [Man 2] Hello Gary.
- How are you?
- [Man 2] Fine, thanks.
- Good.
- [Man 2] You told us that
it's very important
to sell anything by heart.
It's your passion
that's easy, of course, and...
- Selling something
that you believe in.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I couldn't be more
passionate about something.
- [Man 2] Okay.
Now we have a startup, two guys,
and we are in a short period.
We must hire, we
must hire somebody.
And of course,
we want to be sure
that we hire
some guy, some woman
with the same passion.
How can we be sure?
- By being more
focusing on firing than hiring.
- [Man 2] Okay.
- Let me explain.
I think I have the greatest
intuition, EQ, I've ever seen.
It's my biggest
ego, it's all I've got.
I know I'm not that smart.
It's all been intuitive,
and it's been very good to me.
And I've hired
a ton of assholes.
And I really pride myself,
I think I'm really good at it.
I married my wife in
five seconds, all my investments
have been amazing on
intuition, friendships, like
I'm good at it.
And I still have missed.
And so what I've
learned in 20 years is
it's not about the hiring,
because too many people here
are fancy and think
they're so good at hiring,
and it takes them four months,
and they make a hire
and still half of the time
it doesn't work out
and it's just not smart.
What's smart is
go with your gut,
don't cripple yourself.
Now, easy in the U.S.,
I know that in Europe,
there's different kinds
of laws and there's more
finances, I don't know how,
I don't know what your
current state is of like,
fuck, like if you
have to fire somebody
they get seventeen
years of fucking severance.
(audience laughter)
But, you know,
you gotta work your economics,
but what I would
say is regardless
of how painful
it is on the firing,
it is always
firing versus hiring.
You know, you gotta taste it.
- [Man 2] 'Kay.
- That's very important.
That is where the businesses
that have grown the best
have won.
- [Man 2] Don't be
afraid to fire the guy.
- Don't be afraid to fire?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Yeah, no don't
be afraid to fire.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
(audience laughter)
- And by the way,
there's nothing I hate more.
I wish, I wish my
HR and CFO were here.
I drag firing
so long.
I hate confrontation.
I'm a good guy.
I hate it.
It's taken me 20 years
to get better at it,
and I'm still not great at it.
I still fire people
three months, six months,
after I decide.
Six months.
Because I hate it, I feel bad.
It's the worst part
of running a business.
But it is essential.
Because as you
grow your company,
and you get to
seven and nine, and 14,
it's an important skill to have
because here's the problem,
when you don't fire losing
players, winning players leave.
It's a big deal.
- [Man 2] Okay.
- It's a big deal.
- [Man 2] Thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applause)
Let's make sure we get
to this guy eventually.
Oh we can go now, awesome.
That was good execution.
- [Bren] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- My name is Bren,
and I fucking love your energy.
(Gary laughs)
Seriously, you're
such an inspiration.
Keep on, keep going,
keep working, keep hustling.
- I will.
- [Bren] And I'll
always be watching.
- Thank you.
- [Bren] So the question is,
I founded a 3D animation
and virtual reality company
together with my co-founder.
We're doing
actually pretty good.
Every time we get in front
of people, they get excited
on our energy and we
get a human connection.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Now to get
bigger assignments to get
to be able to hire developers,
- [Gary] Yes.
- People don't let
us in, like the bigger
advertising agencies,
they don't see that you have
a hundred people.
They're like, yeah, fuck it.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And in the same sense, we
have a lot of creative energy.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And we want to put that out.
In the same sense,
let's say DRock
wants to make
his own feature film,
- [Gary] Yes.
- He needs a crew.
He needs a crew. He needs
somebody who holds the audio.
He needs somebody
who has the sound.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What is your advice
on creating more revenue
without just
asking money from people?
- [Gary] Yea.
- How do you get more sales
when DRock can only produce
so many videos a day?
- DRock worked for free.
- [Bren] Yeah, did that.
- [Gary] Well,
that's your answer.
Your energy,
that is a human connection.
If your biggest
vulnerability is you need money
to get more people,
get a bunch of
people to work for free.
- [Bren] I don't
want to do that.
- Why?
- [Bren] I don't want to
take advantage of people.
- [Gary]  You're not.
- [Bren] I worked in the game
industry and people were working
at a thousand euros a
day for eighteen hours.
- [Gary] You're confused.
If you're so great,
you are not
taking advantage of them.
I can promise you,
I did not take
advantage of DRock.
(audience laughter)
- Can you leave the stage?
- We sure can.
And the answer is, you
know what's better about that?
That's a really
good way to put it.
What's really most interesting,
is the emails he
gets and why he doesn't
take those opportunities.
Right?
You know what's
great about the game?
It's not the words,
it's not him saying that
with me here or not me
here, it's the actions.
It's the actions.
If you think you're so good,
you wouldn't be
taking advantage of them.
And,
if you don't want to
take advantage of them
because you've made the
romantic point of view that
that's not a good strategy,
well then go make some money.
- [Bren] Well,
(audience laughter)
I get it, I fucking get it.
So, the making
money part, it's okay.
But,--
- [Gary] You can't sell people
that aren't willing to buy.
- Say again?
- [Gary] You can't sell somebody
who's not willing to buy.
If they're
looking at you and saying,
"You don't have a hundred
people and you're too young,"
they're the market,
they're not wrong.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You're wrong.
- Yeah, I get that.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So, what you're saying is,--
- [Gary] What I'm saying is,
you need to realize
that this is all practicality,
and not philosophical.
- I'm asking also as well
for practical information so,--
- [Gary] I just gave it to you.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Practically,
you have two options.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Go make money,
and pay fucking DRock,
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Or,
go figure out that there's
thousands of fucking people
that just want to do the work
'cause they're creative.
And it's better to do it for
a leader that they believe in
than fucking sitting on
their ass in their basement.
- Thank you.
Seriously.
(audience applause)
- [Gary] There is no third move.
You know that's like,
that's the best part, right?
Like what's the third move?
There just isn't.
- [Bren] Those people
at the same time
are working at
that moment for free.
- Yep.
- [Bren] But if their resources
(mumbles) that they can't
pay their student loan.
- Then they won't come to you.
Don't say no for the other guy.
- [Bren] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Hi.
- [Woman] Hello.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Woman] Very good, thank you.
We have something in
common, so I'm very happy today.
- [Gary] We're both very
good looking?
- [Woman] Okay, thank you!
(audience laughter)
Maybe we can talk later then!
Okay.
(Gary laughs)
No, we have
something in common.
I can't sit still,
I'm never quiet,
so that's a bit difficult
for colleagues of mine,
(Gary laughs)
but you just said,
"More firing than hiring."
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Woman] But you
can't just fire somebody
like that, but what do
you do with your people
to keep them motivated, keep
them going, keep them happy?
- You got it.
- How do you do it?
- [Gary] Great question.
The thing we do that has
worked unbelievably well is
I massively
over-invest in realizing
that managing
people is the same way
that I think about marketing.
You can't have one 30 second
video that works for everybody.
I have no idea what
those three care about.
Somebody might care about money.
Somebody might care
about work-life balance.
Somebody might
care about notoriety.
Some might care about
football as their passion,
and I get them
tickets to the World Cup.
I don't care what my
800 employees want in life,
I just want to know what it is.
- [Woman] When you
started, in the beginning,
were you surrounded
by young people or...?
- Both.
When I started the wine
business, I was surrounded
by older people, and I was
22, and that was challenging
'cause I had to break through.
When I started Vayner,
I started it with young people,
but it doesn't
matter how old or young.
I hate when people are like,
"Millennials love work life."
I know tons of
millennials that just want cash.
You know, like,
everybody's different.
When I started out it was easy.
There was only six people
to know every single thing
that they cared
about in the world.
Now it's hard.
Now I've built a
lot of infrastructure.
Now I run a lot of big
data to see what their posting
in social media to know what
they care about in their lives.
I'm obsessed with
knowing what my 800 people want,
because then I can
reverse engineer it,
because I work for them.
Leadership is understanding
that people don't work for you.
that you work for them,
and the best way to build a
great company is retention,
keeping people forever.
My mission, my obsession,
is that everybody that walks
through VaynerMedia
works for me
for the rest of their lives.
To be able to do that,
I need to know what they care
about at 24, what
they care about at 29,
what they care about at 35.
Oh wait, they fell in love.
Oh wait, their
husband wants to move to L.A.
I have to be flexible, nimble,
I have to pay attention,
I have to be obsessed.
- [Woman] I'm starting today.
I'm going to be obsessed.
- Love it.
- [Woman] Okay.
- How many people?
Hold on to it, this is fun.
How many people do you have?
- [Woman] My boss has a lot
of people working for him.
- Yep.
(audience laughter)
- Around 150--
- So you and your boss
and for him, I'm telling
you this is an amazing way
to build a great company.
You have to take
15 and 20 minutes,
you have to take a dinner.
If somebody's very
important, it's dinner
once a quarter, twice a year.
If it's somebody new--
- [Woman] Alright!
- What's that?
(audience laughter)
Got it!
- [Woman] You can
come with us! (laughs)
- But you know what I mean?
That's the key.
I mean some of you
that watch my vlog,
you see five minute meetings
with every single person
that comes in.
It's five minutes, you
can't accomplish that much,
but let me tell you why I do it.
Some people try to razz me,
they think I'm
doing it for show.
I'm not doing it for show.
By sitting with
you for five minutes,
knowing your name,
knowing your phone,
I remember a lot of stuff too.
Knowing if you have a brother
or sister, or you like sports.
When I go into
the elevator with you
in three months
and we go up together
and we can have a 3 minute
conversation, I'm chipping away.
They're scared to talk to me.
I'm the CEO, and
not only am I the CEO,
I'm also internet
famous and a CEO.
So it's really hard for
them to get comfortable,
and I need them to
feel safe to tell me
when something's wrong.
That's the key because the cost
of somebody leaving
is so great, so great.
Much more expensive
than the 15 to 19 hours
that you deploy to stay close,
and remembering that you
need to give them more value
than they're giving to you.
I hate when
leaders, founders, bosses,
expect people to
work as hard as they do.
If you want them to
work as hard as you do,
give them the same economics.
My friend's always like,
"Gary, I can't get my people
"to work as hard as me."
I'm like, "How much do
they own of the company?"
"Nothing."
I'm like, "That's
a starting point."
(audience laughter)
I don't expect
anybody to work as hard as me.
They need to
care about themselves.
They need to execute
for what they're doing.
And then, people are motivated
by very different things.
It's been so interesting to me,
I'm using soccer,
slash your football,
because it's such a
passion in this country.
There's a kid that works
for me, who flat-out told me
that he was considering to leave
because he got offered double--
You know,
Vayner's in tough spot.
We're so hot,
and we're so young,
and there's such big
advertisers in the world
that are trying
to steal our people.
He's like, "Somebody
offered me double my salary.
"But three weeks earlier,
"because you knew I was
a St. Louis baseball fan,
"you came to me and
I was doing a good job,
"and you gave me two tickets."
Randomly.
Not his anniversary,
not his birthday, randomly.
He's like, "That made me stay."
And now he's one of
the most important people
in our paid media team.
Those tickets cost me $937.
- [Woman] Okay,
thank you. (laughs)
(audience laughter)
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Woman] He gave us Gary.
- There you go.
It's amazing, but for
other people, I try to do it,
and they're like take your
fucking trip to Florida back.
Give me $3000, asshole.
You know, like, you
have to know the person.
Everybody has
their own North Star.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Thank you.
Two more?
You know, I love this.
- [William] Hi Gary.
- Hey.
- [William] My name is William,
I've been working for
a year now at a startup.
We've gone from three to
fifteen employees...
- Five-zero or one-five?
- [William] Sorry?
- Fifteen, one five?
- [William] Fifteen,
not fifty, let's
hope we get there.
Influencers...
- Yes.
- [William] And I
feel like I've heard this,
like five years ago, but then
they were called evangelists.
- Okay.
- [William] Where do
you see the difference,
and how to go
about really practical,
how to go about in getting
those on board in the company?
- I think we're
talking about the same thing,
the difference is five
years ago, they had blogs
and they didn't reach anywhere
close to as many people.
I would go into Instagram,
and Facebook fan pages,
and I would
message them, by hand.
- [William] Alright. Do
you have a Facebook account?
- I do, slash Gary.
But remember,
when you approach slash Gary,
figure out what Gary cares
about, not what you care about.
- [William] Alright,
the market's always right.
Thank you.
- You got it.
Yeah, the
market is always right, man.
I'm really glad you
ended with that, bro,
because if you
actually internalize that,
so much changes.
Too much ego in the world,
people think they are so smart,
they latch onto
things like, they latch onto
the guy who created the Porsche,
or the guy that
created the automobile,
legendary, all time billionaire
visionaries, and they go
"Yeah okay, but if Henry Ford
listened to his customers,
"he would have
made a faster horse."
Cool, go be
Henry Ford, you know?
Back to my young man over here,
like, there's four
Facebooks, Facebook, Snapchat,
like, everybody's
going and reverse engineering
all time, all time stuff.
We lack practicality.
There's only two options.
That's business,
not this bullshit
that venture capital, give me,
I mean 98%
of startups in America
are losing money every month.
Like, what do you
think happens when
the economy gets tighter?
There's no next funding round.
Some of the people in
this room have seen it
a couple of times.
(makes rising
and crashing noises)
Because people aren't
smart. They don't realize
when they're up here,
is exactly when they need
to get practical
and change everything,
and make sure
they're not burning money
but making money,
so when it goes this,
then they pick up everything.
I built two businesses,
both during crashes,
I came into Wine Library when
the stock market crashed,
and 9/11 happened
and all my customers lived
in New York and New Jersey.
Built a huge business.
I started VaynerMedia
in the financial crisis
of 2008 and 2009 in America.
I'm a wartime general.
That's a true entrepreneur.
Not when idiots
are giving you funding.
How much talent does it take
to lose money every month?
I think we can all do it.
- [Sophie] Hi Gary, I'm Sophie.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Sophie] I was just wondering,
how do you think the future
of ads agencies looks like?
Because here in
Belgium, we still have
a lot of traditional agencies.
- Yeah.
- [Sophie] Who
are now trying to get
a digital part inside of them.
- Yeah.
- [Sophie] And we also
have the younger agencies,
who are really
digital, digital natives.
- Yes.
- [Sophie] And who are
really performance based.
- Yes.
- [Sophie] But I feel that
in those agency, the really,
the smart marketing,
essence that we used--
- Like strategy and
creative lax, right?
The same
happened with my company.
- [Sophie] The
first ones, they have the,
the real, the great creative
directors and everything,
and the smaller ones,
the young ones, they don't,
but there is this mismatch.
- [Gary] Correct.
- [Sophie] And as a client,
we now need both of them.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Sophie] So how is, how
is this now in the States?
- The big ones are
gonna get disrupted,
they're going to lay off people,
the €230,000 creative director
is gonna go work for
the upstart that survived,
and make €130,
then that one will have it,
then they'll get big, and then
Martin Sorrell will buy 'em.
- [Sophie] Okey-doke.
Alright, thank you.
- So what your
job is as a client,
is to day trade
attention, right?
Like, VaynerMedia was a steal,
for so many years,
still creatively.
Every single one of
my creative directors
are from Crispin Porter,
Wieden & Kennedy, Droga, right?
But were less priced than that,
yet clients buy into the
bullshit like a Cannes Lion,
or what Ad Age said,
so they're stupid.
And so, that's good,
if they're stupid,
they deserve to lose,
and if they're smart,
they deserve to win,
but that's what will happen,
because it's
always happened, right?
So the key is, when
can you find the upstart,
when it has enough
scale and has the nuances
of what you feel they're
missing, because you're right,
when you have two, you know,
they don't work together.
- [Sophie] No they don't.
- Never.
That's not, you know, some
things are great in theory.
It's great on paper, let's get
an above the line
traditional agency,
a digital agency,
a social agency,
and they'll all work together.
Great on paper.
You know what else is
great on paper? Communism.
(audience laughter)
It's great. Like if you read it,
it seems really good,
it just doesn't
match to the human spirit.
You can't ask two
companies who both want
to build their
business to play nice,
when they're both
undermining each other
to get more business.
And that's why my
companies really worked
in the sandbox, because
I've taught all my people
to just assume that's
what everybody's doing.
We're not mad when the
agencies do that to us,
that's what
they're supposed to do.
What I tell them
to do, my people,
even the most senior, is to
eat shit, be the bigger person.
I'll take care of it up here,
and it's worked very well
cause the client can feel who
is trying to make it work,
and who's not.
- [Sophie] Alright, thank you.
- Cool, yep.
- A couple more
and then we'll go.
- [Yama] Hello.
- Hello.
- I'm Yama, I
just would like to know
what you would
consider personally
your biggest business mistake
you made in your career.
- That's a great question.
I said this the other
day with DRock, I'm like,
"I hate this question,
because I have no respect,
"or time, or
energy for my failures,
"and so I don't
think about them as much."
I think, I mean
there's a lot, look,
my first book was
called "Crush It!",
and in the acknowledgements,
if you go get it
in the library right now,
I thank my entire family
and one random person:
Travis, the founder
and CEO of Uber.
Travis came to me, and
wanted me to invest in Uber,
and I passed, twice.
That $50,000 investment,
because that was the
size of what I was writing,
would now be worth
close to $400 million.
That's a bad move.
(audience laughter)
So that's, that's not
as valuable to everybody.
I'll tell you what's
valuable to everybody.
Every time in my
career that my eyes got big,
and I decided,
so what I do very
well, I referenced
the 100 and 67 million thing,
I'm very good at making
80% of my business stable,
tried-and-true,
staying the course,
continuing to do
what I know will work,
and then taking 20%
of my money and energy
and being very risky,
and trying to put myself
out of business.
Back to the agency
question, what's the agency
that's coming next
that could hurt me.
Is it a VR shop? I'm trying
to put myself out of business.
I'm very good at that,
and that's why I build
very big businesses. I'm not
as profitable every year,
but I get really big, got it?
When I've taken
that out of my control,
and have given
money and some energy
to other companies and put
a founder and CEO in charge,
like I did after
I left Wine Library
and started VaynerMedia for a
social network called Cork'd,
which was a wine social network,
for a company called
Forrest, which was a designer
and developer social network,
where I was the "co-founder",
but I really wasn't
running the company,
it was mainly,
I was giving money,
we leveraged my name, I would
check in once in a while,
I've done very poorly.
- So, what I've
learned is, when I'm operating
and building scale around me,
it's a very good strategy,
financially worthwhile,
when I've gotten big eyes
and I wanna do
everything and support other
entrepreneurs, in a
world where I try my best
to vet them, but they
may be good or they may not
be good, those have
been some of the places
where I've made a mistake.
And I think, I'll
be honest with you,
I think my greatest
mistake is still ahead of me.
Because of the way I play.
Where I will have a
great mistake is that I hedged
so much, I invest so much,
I'm building so much
for the future,
that I may not achieve
my great ambitions
because I left too many dollars
along the way in
a thirty year macro
and at 70 or 75 or 80, when
I realize shit, I don't have
a lot more time, it
could get me into a place
where I become
cynical and bitter
because I left so much,
I did so much
for everybody else.
The 51-49 that I give to
everybody else hurt me
in the end and so I could
become this weird character
that goes and lives
in a cave out of anger
in my old years and
young entrepreneurs are gonna
try and find me
and shit like that so,
that's how I think
my story could end.
And I mean that.
I think my greatest
failure is at the end.
My intuition is I'll
convince myself that the journey
and the legacy trumped
whatever materialistic thing
I wanted, I kind of
already know that too, yeah.
Okay, one more and then we
should get on schedule right,
cause I'm fucking it up, yeah.
- [Sebastian] Hi Gary.
- Hello.
- [Sebastian] It's Sebastian.
- Hey Sebastian.
- [Sebastian] Yeah you've
touched on
influencer marketing
briefly already.
- Yes.
- [Sebastian] And I've dabbled
in it a little bit so far.
- Okay.
- [Sebastian] But the problem
is that a lot of the clients
they actually well
treat it as product placement
or endorsements.
- Okay.
- [Sebastian] Do you think it
works in that respect, or not?
- Well I think that's what
it looks like historically,
do you mean that
they're forcing the influencer
to do something
very specifically.
- [Sebastian] This is
my product.
- Yeah, not smart.
- [Sebastian] Put it in
your hands and put it on.
- Yeah, I think the only way
to do influencer marketing
is to give the product
to the person and tell them
to do whatever the
fuck they want with it.
The problem is the
brands wanna control the message
and they may say that's off
brand, they don't understand
that's very much on brand
because the interpretation
of that product to that
audience where that person
intuitively understands
that audience
is exactly what you want.
- [Sebastian] How
would you suggest I,--
- By,
- [Sebastian] Try to
convey that to the clients?
- By not taking their money
unless they do it your way.
- [Sebastian] Thanks
that makes sense.
- It's, it makes sense,
it's the right answer
it's also very difficult to do.
You know one of the
great things about being good
at what you do is it
allows you to say no.
So I have given you advice
that's right but it might not
be practical
because that might be
the only way you make money
but you need to
fight for it harder
than you're fighting for it.
You have to be
willing to lose the client,
you'll be surprised,
four out of every ten times,
the client will be
even more excited because
the client-agency
thing is hilarious.
The client's want more strategy,
but when the agencies
bring the right strategy
they try to make
it the wrong strategy.
Like people hire us all
the time and then I'll sit
in the first meeting
and I'm like, you guys hired
VaynerMedia, not J.W.T.,
what the fuck are you trying
to make us do that?
You could have just go
fucking hire Poolassist
you fucker.
- [Sebastian] Thanks.
- You're welcome.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience applause)
(light music)